let's talk about how to fix the adrenal
body type okay so are we talking about
adrenal fatigue are we talking about
some adrenal disease well the medical
profession doesn't acknowledge adrenal
fatigue they don't really think that it
exists and that's totally fine because
what are they going to do just give you
another drug give you a steroid I think
if you have adrenal stress adrenal
burnout adrenal fatigue whatever you
want to call it I think you should use
natural type remedies so the first
question is where are the adrenals well
they're located right above the kidney
right on top of the kidneys okay you
have two of them and they're little
triangle glands and they have an inside
and an outside the outside is called the
cortex adrenal cortex and then the
inside is called the medulla the Adrenal
medulla the main hormone that we're
going to focus on on the outside is
called cortisol and then the
neurotransmitter on the inside that
we're going to focus on is called
adrenaline and the entire adrenal system
relates to something called Fight or
Flight and that relates to its purpose
which is to adapt the body to a stress
State now what does that mean adapt the
body to a stress State well it's quite
interesting that you have an entire
system that adapts your body to this
very interesting condition or state
which is during stress whether you're
attacking something fighting something
or you're running away from something
okay you have a system to help you
survive so what this system does through
all of its different adaptations is to
prepare your body to survive during a
stress mode and of course this was
designed to be more short-term not
long-term like we experience nowadays
with sustained chronic mental stress our
bodies were designed to handle a bit
more physical stress so you need more
blood flow to certain muscles you need
more heightened energy in your brain to
focus in on certain things and solve
certain problems relating to survival
you need quick energy as in glucose
energy and you don't need energy to
certain body systems like reproduction
like the immune system
like your digestion so that's the
function of the adrenals and these
hormones go through almost every cell in
the body and start to change certain
things to adapt the body to prepare for
this stress situation so what's the
significance of that well
if you're under chronic mental stress
okay or you have major losses in your
life or you have surgeries or traumas
which by the way all these stresses
accumulate over time and then they
create situations where the adrenals
become dysfunctional to a certain degree
and I'm not even talking about a disease
I'm talking about like a subclinical
problem with the adrenal at first you
have a higher level of these hormones
and then over time you start developing
like cortisol resistance just like
insulin resistance where now the
cortisol doesn't work but you have high
levels of cortisol and symptoms of low
cortisol it makes it really confusing
but let's go through the symptoms that
someone might experience if they have
adrenal fatigue or adrenal dysfunction
number one their tolerance for stress is
lowered they can't tolerate babysitting
a room full of small children at a
daycare center for more than eight hours
they can't tolerate a slow driver in
front of them for a period of you know
two and a half hours where they're on
the freeway for some reason that bothers
them they definitely can't tolerate
incompetent people or people that are
considered more stupid or people that
make maybe stupid decisions they just
have a low tolerance for that unless
they're an environment where everything
is logical and perfect they get
impatient they become irritable and they
have sometimes even anxiety and anxiety
is like worry and an inability to decide
on something because there's a chronic
problem the moment someone decides and
solves a problem the anxiety is less now
it can also affect excessive thinking
analyzing things especially when you're
trying to sleep you know in the middle
of the night you're solving all these
problems and just keep going and going
and going
that's an adrenal symptom and because
the adrenals the cortisol is another
name for that is called glucocorticoid
you actually turn protein into glucose
so you're running your body on glucose
and that's something that your adrenals
basically cause your liver to make more
sugar to run on sugar fuel because it's
quick energy the problem is
stress really equals sugar and even
though you're not eating sugar you're
getting a lot of sugar in the
bloodstream and that can cause blood
sugar problems and even believe it or
not diabetes and what's happening with
all the sugar is that it's going to be
converted to cholesterol not the
friendly type also you're getting
conversion into fat on the liver fat in
the visceral organs right here because
that's a survival mechanism to hold fat
in the midsection in fact in really
extreme examples I'll show you in this
book right here siba a collection of
medical illustrations volume 4 endocrine
system
see this is an adrenal body type right
here you can see the person's holding
fat right here and then the body is
extracting protein from the glutamus
Maximus and putting it right into that
that part right here and then taking
muscle from this extra muscle here
called the quads putting that right in
that midsection right here so there's
all these physiological things that
happen throughout the body which I'm
going to get into another thing that
happens with the adrenal is they get
hyper acidity gastritis and this is why
some people can experience ulcers from
stress because the stress activates this
acidity which then Burns a hole right
through your stomach the blood pressure
goes up with adrenal okay you have
increased pulse rate you can have the
symptom of asthma and because you get
cortisol resistance cortisol is normally
an anti-inflammatory but now you have
have the opposite of that which is a
deficiency of cortisol in the cell and
this is why a lot of people with adrenal
problems develop inflammation that won't
go away they start developing all sorts
of inflammatory disorders and problems
within the immune system in fact if we
just look at inflammation where that
comes from
it comes from the healing response it
can come from an injury it can come from
the immune system but the immune system
controls inflammation in the body
regardless of where it comes from but
the unique thing about the adrenal
system is that it's shunting energy away
from the immune system and this is why
the white blood cells which is your
entire immune system is suppressed
during stress and cortisol this is why
they use cortisol or prednisone as a
treatment with immune overactivity type
inflammatory conditions so in other
words when you go through stress and you
have high levels of cortisol your immune
system becomes paralyzed okay and you
can even develop in that state
autoimmune diseases and so many people
develop an autoimmune disease right
after a stress event or a major loss so
any condition that involves inflammation
is a condition that involves the adrenal
glands you're also losing certain things
like calcium you're losing potassium for
sure and initially you're retaining
sodium but then eventually when the
adrenals burn out you'll lose sodium so
you're losing these electrolytes and a
little uh point about potassium is when
you start losing potassium the pH
changes in the body to a more alkaline
state so anytime you're looking at a
loss of potassium that's associated with
an alkaline state so when people are
burnt out they're not more acidic
they're more alkaline and that affects
their breathing they tend to get hypoxia
or
breathing problems they can't breathe as
well they accumulate a bit too much CO2
and not enough oxygen I mean even if you
look at someone that is in a panic state
right they're breathing and they're
they're breathing like crazy they
basically are getting too much oxygen
and not the right balance of CO2 because
CO2 is needed in a certain amount to
help them absorb oxygen but they have
this imbalance of air and they're just
suffocating
when they're under a panic attack or
even in an anxiety state if you take a
look at someone that's in anxiety look
at their breathing it's not regular it's
like
it's kind of like it's not balanced and
this is why regulating the breath can
correct an anxiety state really fast and
even take someone out of a panic attack
especially if they breathe through their
nose and they breathe slowly in and they
breathe slowly out another thing that's
interesting with the adrenals is vitamin
D you tend to lose vitamin D very easily
with an adrenal situation and so the
need for certain nutrients especially
vitamin D goes up as you lose the
adrenal function
now if we talk about cortisol cortisol
is very similar in function to vitamin D
they act in similar ways they're both
anti-inflammatory and so any condition
that you have that has a problem with
cortisol I would recommend using vitamin
D as a remedy okay so that conclude any
of the anti-inflammatory conditions like
back pain or knee pain or any of that
stuff versus a shot of Prednisone so
here's the picture of the adrenal body
type an exaggerated picture like I said
the midsection no butt weakened thigh
muscles you can have memory loss brain
fog but at night everything becomes more
active especially around two o'clock in
the morning where you're you wake up and
you're thinking about problems things
like that in fact with classical adrenal
problems you're more awake at two
o'clock than you are in the morning when
you're trying to wake up climbing up a
flight of stairs you get out of breath
easier and you might possibly even crave
salty things like chips things like that
now when you go to sleep at night
there's a four waves of sleep that you
go through okay and there's really deep
levels of sleep called the Delta wave
sleep and you have the superficial ones
which are called REM so when you go to
sleep the purpose of sleep is just to
get rid of a lot of toxins in the brain
and metabolites that are generated
through the day which are kind of
byproducts of metabolism also you're
getting kind of a Rejuvenation of
neurotransmitters when you're sleeping
and so sleep is necessary for the
recovery of stress yet stress inhibits
sleep so it's definitely
a catch-22 cortisol just messes up the
adrenal circadian wave because
everything is backwards with the
adrenals the lowest point of cortisol is
that two o'clock or 2 30 a.m right and
the highest point is at 8 A.M in the
morning so with adrenal fatigue you'll
see it's just the opposite you're very
awake at too but you really want to
sleep like seven or eight o'clock in the
morning but you have that's when you
have to get up I had this adrenal
problem so bad in my 20s and 30s as well
mainly in my late 20s I started to get
better actually at 28 but here's the
thing it would take me until 11 o'clock
AM to finally wake up in my head now of
course my diet wasn't helping because I
would be living on carbs but boy did I
have adrenal problems big time I would
wake up at 2 2 30. there was one night
well multiple nights but I remember one
that I didn't even sleep one minute I
laid there all night long listening to
my wife Karen saw logs it was torture I
remember it was like seven or eight
o'clock and I'd get up and I didn't even
sleep one minute I was like this is
driving me crazy you talk about stress
like just not sleeping I mean it's it's
terrible here's a question how can
someone know what's wrong in the body in
relationship to the adrenals is there a
task that can be done is there a blood
test is there a saliva test
the problem is
um those aren't really good testing
because these hormones travel on the
Circadian wave and so if you just check
one blood test or one saliva test with
your cortisol you're just getting a
snapshot of what's happening at that
period of time to really know what's
going on you have to check it every four
hours which is a real pain in the butt
okay so there is a saliva test that you
can do that and I've done that and
that's good but it's it's kind of a pain
in the butt to do and also takes time
and it's a little expensive I'm going to
show you a way better test that's
Dynamic that's inexpensive virtually
free and it really tells you the
function of the adrenals versus a very
static test and that is the problem
nowadays with testing just about
anything they use static tests they do
CAT scans MRIs which is fine to measure
like tumors and masses and stuff like
that but that doesn't check the function
of something whether it's the
gallbladder or the digestive system them
or the hormone flow it doesn't look at
that the first one is called the raglins
test and all you need is a blood
pressure cuff okay that's all you need
so that's the expense of it and you
check your blood pressure laying down
while you're relaxing okay and you're
checking the top number and the bottom
number you have the systolic top number
and the bottom number is the diastolic
you're primarily interested in the
systolic number that's the top number
only okay so you check your blood
pressure line down and then you stand up
and you check the blood pressure that's
all you have to do and just record it
okay the difference between the systolic
and the diastolic is that the systolic
is measuring the sympathetic nervous
system the contraction and the diastolic
is measuring the parasympathetic it just
so happens to be a 50 50 split of
sympathetic
and parasympathetic and what's
interesting about the adrenals is it has
no parasympathetic innervation
okay so in other words it only has an on
switch sympathetic and no off switch and
I think this is one of the reasons why
when you go through stress it's
sometimes it's hard to turn it off
because we don't just have an off switch
on your adrenals there's no
parasympathetic involvement so you're
looking at this systolic number right
now normally when you lie down and stand
up there's an adrenal adaptation that
increases the blood pressure in the
pulse rate to be able to push the blood
up into the brain or you would literally
pass out have you ever like stood up
real quickly and felt dizzy well that is
a failure of the adrenal system to pump
the blood pressure and blood up to your
brain fast enough so you don't pass out
there's a severe condition called pots
which I'm not going to get into but
that's a severe adrenal problem so
anyway when you lie down and stand up
that top number should go up a certain
amount like six to ten points
if it goes up a lot more or it drops
down there's an adrenal dysfunction okay
usually if it goes up too fast it's
usually more of an earlier sign of
adrenal fatigue where your adrenals are
overreacting and then when it starts to
go down I've seen this all the time
where the systolic just drops white down
by 10 points and the person feels really
dizzy this is just the lack of adrenal
gland function the adrenals are weak
they can't adapt to stress so if they
were to run upstairs
boy they would feel very very weak and
they we just wouldn't have the endurance
and that's one good test is can you do
an incline easily or not
people that have good adrenals can but
they can go incline they can do rock
climbing they can they can run up a hill
no problem with no side effects at all
but the simple Dynamic adaptive stress
tests raglan's test is a good clue on
what's going on with the adrenal so
that's number one
number two evaluates your CO2 tolerance
and remember I talked about breathing
and oxygen and your pH being off well
that relates to adrenal fatigue and this
test is going to measure your tolerance
to CO2 so you see you have oxygen and
then you have CO2
and as you know you need oxygen it takes
a little bit of CO2 for oxygen to go
into the cells but you can't live off
just CO2 there's going to be a sensation
of anxiety if you have too much CO2 and
not enough oxygen in fact if you
suffocate someone they're going to go
immediately into anxiety and then panic
attack so here's what you do breathe
through your nose step one okay you're
going to breathe in
breathe in and breathe out three times
through your nose okay on the fourth
inhalation you're going to take it as
much air as you can
okay and then what you're going to do is
you're going to have a timer and you're
going to time in seconds
what is the time of exhalation you're
gonna breathe out slowly okay after this
very large inhalation if at the end of
the exhalation where you can't have any
more air come out equals 20 seconds or
less this means that you don't have a
very good tolerance to CO2 this is a
poor adaptation this means you have
adrenal fatigue if your number is
between 20 and 40 seconds this is like
average if the seconds are between 40
and 60 seconds this is kind of like a
little bit above average but not quite
great but if you can do this between 60
and 80 Seconds you're Advanced or even
over 80 Seconds you're an elite athlete
and this brings up a really important uh
thing about exercise the more fit that
you can get your body the more capacity
you can handle stress in life and that's
one important reason why you should get
in shape and start exercising all right
so what does the adrenal need to recover
the most important vitamin okay is
vitamin C for the adrenals why because
both cortisol and adrenaline and these
other neurotransmitters in the inside of
the adrenal need Vitamin C as a
precursor very very important if you
don't have enough vitamin C you're going
to have all sorts of problems and
probably the fatigue that you get from
scurvy which is a severe vitamin C
deficiency is probably a similar thing
you're experiencing an adrenal fatigue
but if you look at this image right here
I have a picture of ascorbic acid which
most people think is Vitamin C but
really it's just the shell it's the
artificial or synthetic part or one part
of the vitamin C complex in nature you
never see just pure ascorbic acid you
have the whole ball of wax the whole
complex and this is why it's so
important to get a vitamin C from a food
extract the best source would be
sauerkraut make sure it's raw you can
have like like 700 milligrams that's 7x
what you normally need with vitamin C
sauerkraut also bell peppers uh any of
the leafy green vegetables lemons limes
berries are loaded with vitamin C
another really important nutrient is
potassium okay you get that from large
salads
people that don't have a lot of salad or
vegetables and have adrenal fatigue boy
they have a hard time winding down you
see potassium is kind of like a
physiological tranquilizer it calms
things down and if you ever hear your
pulse rate pound in your ear when you're
trying to sleep that's a potassium
deficiency potassium is going to help
you relax when I don't consume enough
salad for example to get my potassium my
sleep isn't that great I'm kind of on
edge but when I do have enough potassium
from salads and things like that I feel
better I just feel calm so potassium is
necessary and then with those vegetables
also comes magnesium which is also good
for the adrenals but mainly potassium
now sodium is also needed in most cases
if the adrenal glands are really burnt
out you need more salt sea salt but
unfortunately people get it from the
wrong Source potato chips corn chips
things like that you want to get it to
Salt your food more sea salt that can
help as well some people when they
consume C so they can breathe better
because the the pH kind of normalizes
from either one extreme to back to
normal the other nutrient that's really
important with the adrenal is vitamin B1
now vitamin B1 is probably the most
important nutrient not necessarily just
for the adrenals but for the entire
autonomic nervous system especially
starting in the brain stem itself right
back here
and that goes right through the adrenal
system so you have a lot of connections
between those two but um if you're
deficient in B1 uh boy you'll have a
problem with breathing and boy will you
have a problem with stress so B1 can
very quickly within minutes just calm
you down and make things do better with
within the autonomic nervous system from
just a different angle so what is the
plan and protocol for the adrenal
there's a lot of things that can be done
number one
um find the source of stress that you're
going through and do whatever you can to
fix it
very important and then with that change
your viewpoint on just
life in general just keep a more relaxed
viewpoint on things I did a video on
this very important just to go through
life with a bit of a Carefree Viewpoint
just a relaxed Viewpoint because
unfortunately when people under a lot of
stress they get really serious and that
doesn't help them so you really want to
just change the way that you look at
things and even wherever you're holding
your tension you want to relax that all
right number two yes you want to be in a
ketogenic diet but you want to add a
little bit more protein okay make sure
it's high quality protein
you want to make sure you get enough
potassium so that's the big salads you
also want to get enough vitamin C like I
said from the big salads that can give
you the vitamin C as well and of course
we want that sea salt as well and the B1
nutritional yeast is a really good
source get the unfortified version
that's the tweak on the keto and then
the next thing is to start to exercise
in a way that builds up your capacity to
deal with more stress combine that with
long walks aerobic that flushes out that
adrenaline in a cortisol for the day as
well as um higher intensity exercise
with short duration lots of recovery so
you can build up your Fitness that is
probably going to be one of the most
successful things that you can do for
stress to counter stress because it's
impossible to eliminate it because you
live on planet Earth and the last thing
is to add these adaptogens I like
ashwagandha the best but that herb boy
it just
it just makes you feel chilled out it's
a really good effect for people that are
under stress and you should just try it
if you've never tried it before it'll
just kind of mellow you out and and help
and just take it as needed all right so
now you have a plan to actually fix the
adrenal body type but if you haven't
seen this video on how to change your
viewpoint on stress and be calm during
stress I put that up right here check it
out